des fleurs des photos des bougies des
messages de sympathie ce monument devant
le palais de justice de laval est est
devenu un lieu de recueillement à la
mémoire de daphné caruana galicia une
journaliste d'investigation assassiné le
16 octobre 2010 est à 15 heures cette
journée là une bombe placée dans sa
voiture explose alors qu'elle venait de
quitter sa maison
le véhicule calciné termine sa course au
milieu d'un champ
le meurtre suscite l'indignation pays et
dans le monde
les maleterres demande du stif et
surtout veulent connaître la vérité
si les tueurs à gage présumés sont
rapidement arrêtés les commanditaires du
meurtre
eux n'ont toujours pas été identifiés
10/06/2009 - manuel délia revient
souvent sur les lieux du crime vers les
cookies et 1 nm provice schirrhein
aujourd'hui transformé en lieu de
mémoire
c'est toujours difficile pour moi de
venir ici je la connaissais je ne dirais
pas que c'était une amie mais elle été
un mentor pour moi un exemple
daphné caruana galicia était un cas à
part dans le paysage médiatique maltais
journaliste opiniâtre elle enquêtait et
dénoncé sans relâche sur son blog la
corruption les trafics illicites
les pots-de-vin raft s'est créée ces
derniers mots écrits une heure avant sa
mort sont toujours en ligne
il y a maintenant des escrocs partout où
l'on regarde la situation est désespérée
depuis manuel zelaya a tout laissé pour
prendre le relais donnons nous à ce
contenu
sur son blog il a repris les enquêtes de
daphné et ses combats entre la
corruption réunion sans même m'en rendre
compte je suis devenu journaliste et
j'ai réalisé que je ne pourrai plus
faire autre chose
manuel écrit plusieurs fois par jour
avec acharnement
sa quête de vérité savoir qui a tué
daphné et pourquoi est devenu pour lui
une obsession
la vérité est enterrée quelque part et
tout le monde creuse pour la découvrir
sans vraiment savoir où elle se trouve
je veux faire ma part ces articles sont
aujourd'hui lui chaque jour par des
milliers de maltais les pistes que je
suis aujourd'hui manuels sont nombreuses
car daphné caruana galicia avait
beaucoup d'ennemis elle avait dénoncé
tour à tour le président d'azerbaïdjan
et plusieurs membres du gouvernement
maltais les accusant de corruption de
malversation
on parle ici de corruption qui implique
le premier ministre je ne serai pas
satisfait tant que ceux qui ont ordonné
le meurtre de daphné caruana gallizia ne
seront pas derrière les barreaux
mais contrairement à daphné manuel n'est
aujourd'hui plus seul dans son combat
pour la vérité
samantha a repris lui aussi le flambeau
et publiés jusqu'ici une trentaine
d'articles d'investigation son sujet
qu'il a même reçu l'appui d'un groupe de
journaux internationaux comme le monde
et le guardian qui ont mis sur pied le
projet daphné pour mettre en commun les
ressources et les documents une aide de
poids car la rédaction du times of malta
compte moins de dix journalistes
certainement besoin le fait d'être plus
nombreux et très rassurant un article
publié dans le times of malta aura un
impact limité
mais lorsqu'un article est publié en
même temps par terre vous le guardian ça
donne un impact mondial des cowboys
enquête sans relâche depuis des mois sur
le sujet honnêtement je pense qu'on ne
fait qu'effleurer la surface
c'est ce qui est le plus horrible plus
on creuse plus on trouve des liens
ça semble sans fin la recherche de la
vérité dans un si petit pays est loin
d'être aisée car tout le monde connaît
tout le monde à malte et la loi du
silence est bien souvent la règle
obtenir l'information a toujours été
difficile et ce elle l'est maintenant
encore davantage parce que les membres
du gouvernement et les institutions
savent que nous articles sont à leur
sujet alors il ne collabore pas beaucoup
malgré les douzaine d'articles publiés
jusqu'ici amat le daphné project n'a pas
encore eu de retombées concrètes ni
judiciaires ni politique
le gouvernement a plutôt réagi par la
défiance et la bravade
steijns augmenta a aussi des menaces et
poursuites pour plusieurs millions de
dollars
la rédaction demeure déterminée liberté
de la presse est en jeu avec la mort de
daphné car la volonté était de la
réduire au silence elle et tous les
journalistes de maths mais c'est aussi
la démocratie qui est en jeu car la
presse est un pilier de la démocratie de
presse doit napper les automobiles
s'il est conscient des risques s'ils
avouent regarder sous sa voiture chaque
fois qu'il se déplace manuel délia se
fait aussi la promesse chaque jour
d'aller jusqu'au bout quoi qu'il arrive
nous avons une obligation morale là même
qui motivait d'affiner révéler la vérité
est confronté les responsables et que le
responsable fo
[Musique]